ça m'est arrivé dans le métro tout à
l'heure en arrivant dans l'émission j'ai
pris un ticket et des contrôleurs sont
rentrés dans la rame mais mon moment est
mon ticket j'aurais dû le tickets
contrairement aux voisins ils m'ont dit
ticket et lui il a dit et toi Tiki
[Applaudissements]
c'est un italien en américain et un
Algérien ils sont dans le désert et dans
le désert on leur a dit vous avez le
droit de prendre une chose avec vous
pour vous protéger du soleil américain
il prend un parasol comme ça dit voilà
s'il y a trop de soleil je prends le
parasol et je vais me faire un petit
coin d'ombre l'italien dis-moi je vais
prendre une gourde avec de l'eau comme
ça s'il fait trop chaud je vais
m'hydrater et l'Algérie dit moi je vais
prendre une portière comme ça si il fait
trop chaud je vous la fenêtre
alors ces deux fouilles sont dans un
hôpital psychiatrique
et dans cet hôpital il y a une piscine
et les deux fous marchent au bord de la
piscine il y en a un des deux qui jette
dans la piscine qui commence à se noyer
le deuxième il vague le sauve et tout et
en apprenant ça le responsable de
l'hôpital
vu qu'il a fait ça en actéroïque je vais
lui offrir sa sortie je vais le laisser
sortir donc tu vas le voir dans sa
chambre il écoute tu as fait un acte
héroïque c'est super ce que tu as fait
au moins tu es conscience j'ai
conscience que toi tu es conscient je
vais te laisser sortir de l'hôpital ça
c'est la bonne nouvelle par contre la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est que la personne
que tu as sauvé elle s'est pas rendu
dans sa chambre lui dit non pas pendu
moi accroché pour qu'il sèche
l'histoire d'un français d'un anglais et
d'un Algérien sont prisonnier
excusez-moi et ils sont ils sont
emprisonnés dans des dans les cellules
tu sais à l'ancienne des western là où
il y a les barreaux il décide de
s'enfuir mais seulement pendant le
sommeil du gardien parce qu'il y a un
gardien devant la séduit donc le soir
arrive le gardien commence à s'endormir
français qui va et il arrive à ouvrir la
cellule il sort il fait du bruit
arrivant arriver devant le gardien
gardien qui va là le français fait miaou
vous dire le fait mieux que moi
il réussit le gardien dit c'est bon
c'est un chat c'est bon français réussi
à s'échapper l'anglais il va pareil il
arrive dans le gardien il fait du bruit
regardez qui va là
c'est bon c'est un chat c'est bon
l'anglais réussir à s'évader arrive
et j'ai mis il arrive ils ont gardien il
fait du bruit regarde
[Applaudissements]